I find that it helps me to break these down. So I'm going to start with just
imaging printing the first row. This for loop might seem a little bit silly,
but once I write it, I can compare it to the one for the second row. For each
column, I want to print out a pair of square brackets, but in this case, the
columns start at the first column and only go up to the first column. So
that'll look like this. The for loop for the second row will look pretty
similar except it'll print two pairs of brackets. One for column 1, one for
column 2. So this is interesting, instead of something changing inside the
loop, it's the actual loop condition itself that's changing form row to row.
The threshold is actually the row itself, now these are exactly the same. So I
could set row to 1 and do this and then increment row to 2 and do the exact
same thing. Which means that I can put this code into a loop. So I'll indent
it, remove the extra repetitions and now instead of just setting row to 1, I'll
actually loop over all of the rows starting at 1. And going while row is less
than or equal to the total number of rows. Let's see how much progress we've
made after fixing typos. Well, it's certainly printing some brackets. Let's put
some line breaks between the rows. Much better. This was kind of neat. In this
problem, we used the outer loop variable to control the number of iterations in
the inner loop. The loop condition of the inner loop depends on the loop
counter variable for the outer loop.